[MUSIC]
Do you think you're tough?
How tough?
How much adversity can you overcome?
I want to give you
a couple of scenarios and
I want you to take a second,
put yourself in each one.
What would you do if your boss
gave you a negative review?
What would you if you pitched your
startup, and the investor passed?
What would you do if the company you
spent 20 years building went bankrupt?
What would you do if you
were diagnosed with cancer?
Now this guy in front is thinking,
whoa whoa, that first set of questions
is completely different from
that second set of questions.
A bad review is nothing like cancer.
And I would say, exactly,
that's the point of my talk.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I want to show that not only are there
different kinds of adversity, there
are also different kinds of resilience.
There are lots of words for
this characteristic.
Resilience, emotional fortitude,
toughness, grit.
They have slightly different meanings.
They overlap some, but by and
large, they refer to the ability of
individuals to overcome adversity.
The problem is that no
matter what words we use,
we tend to think of it
as a single spectrum.
Really weak people get
overwhelmed by one bad review.
Really tough people can watch their
whole career go up in smoke, and
not miss a step.
But that doesn't capture all of it.
As the guy in front pointed out,
these are different kinds of stressors.
It would make sense that they would
illicit different reactions, and
require different coping mechanisms,
even from a tough person.
This has been bothering me and I had
a sudden burst of clarity when I realized
that these same words that we used to
describe people, also have meanings when
they describe the ways that physical
materials deform under stress.
In mechanical engineering, deformation and
reaction to stress follows
an established pattern.
Materials first deform elastically,
which is to say that they
bend in response to stress.
But when the stress is removed,
they bend back.
This period of elastic deformation
continues to a point called
the yield strength.
Here's some calculus, you ready?
>> [LAUGH]
>> The area under the curve between
the origin and yield strength
is actually called toughness.
Toughness is effectively a measure of
how much stress the material can take
and still recover.
It dovetails remarkably well with
definitions that we see in psychology.
In mechanical engineering,
there's a little bit more.
What happens when stress
exceeds yield strength?
Mechanically, it's called
plastic deformation.
The material bends permanently or
even breaks at what's known as a fracture
point, which leads to what happened to me.
I fractured my tibial plateau,
where the shin bone meets the knee joint,
I was tobogganing and
I lost control, hit a pole.
To mitigate the risks of internal
bleeding, I needed surgery that night.
Surgeons drilled two metal
rods into my tibia, and
two metal rods into my femur, connected
all four with an external fixation device.
A week later, I had another surgery in
which they implanted a metal rod and
a dozen screws.
All told, the sentence was 16 days in
the hospital, 12 weeks on crutches,
a year of physical therapy,
and unknown permanent damage.
I hit my fracture point, literally.
How does that happen?
It's different for everyone, but
I'd say we go there when something really
important to us changes permanently.
A job, a reputation, a relationship,
or in my case, a leg.
That idea of permanent damage to
the leg that I had intended to use for
marathon running and mountain climbing,
the leg that I was maybe a little vainly
proud of, hit me hard,
harder than other challenges I'd overcome.
Somehow, I couldn't help but think,
what if this weren't my leg?
How would I react if this were my company?
That was a scary thought.
I'd long nurtured
entrepreneurial inclinations and
the market can dish out plenty
of challenges of its own.
If I was flat on my
back with a broken leg,
how could I reasonably expect to lead in
the face of corporate-sized adversity?
This is where mechanical engineering,
of all things, made so much sense to me.
Mechanically, there are two types
of deformation reactions in
response to stress.
In elastic deformation, materials bend but
they end up back where they were,
in plastic deformation they bend or
break and need to be rebuilt.
I think that people bend two different
ways as well and that means there should
be two different such a skills for coping
with stress, but we mostly talk about one.
We call people resilient when they can
take a punch and get right back up.
Being tough is certainly a good goal,
it's been one of mine for a long time.
But what about being good at rebuilding?
What do you do after,
not just a punch but a knockout?
That was something I hadn't been taught,
and so
I went about trying to
find best practices.
My favorites came from
the field of survivorship,
research on people who have made it
out of life and death situations.
The first thing successful
survivors do right
is move quickly from denial to acceptance.
They don't dwell on what's been lost or
think about the unfairness
of their predicament.
Even in non-life threatening situations,
that's so much easier said than done.
But it can be done.
When Jimmy Carter lost the election in
1980, he said that he went home, slept for
an entire day and awoke to what he called
a new, unwanted, potentially empty life.
Unwanted, that's the tricky part.
But only potentially empty.
Carter never became president again, but
he did move on to international conflict
mediation and the Nobel Peace Prize.
A second trait of successful survivors
is the ability to set small goals and
the willingness to celebrate small wins.
Recognizing even small victories can help
prevent a descent into hopelessness.
In 2013, ski racer Lindsey Vonn
suffered a catastrophic crash.
She tore her ACL, MCL, meniscus and
fractured her tibial plateau.
I can't know whether she
did any wallowing but
I do know that two days after surgery,
she was doing core strength exercises.
Three weeks after surgery,
she was on a bike.
As soon as she could bear weight,
she did squats.
She didn't actually ski for 203 days but
by the time she did, she was strong.
Finally, survivors get help but
they also give it.
Giving help takes you out of yourself.
It lets you be a rescuer, not a victim.
When Mickey Drexler was fired
from his role as CEO of the GAP,
he found another company to help,
in the form of a struggling J.Crew brand.
He invested $10 million of his own money,
took one-tenth of his former salary, and
managed to catapult the company from a $30
million operating loss to a $37
million profit in just a year.
Move on from what's lost,
set small goals, get and give help.
Whether these things really make
the difference, I'm not sure.
I'm trying.
What I do know is that all of us,
at some point, either already have or
will need to rebuild and
I'm convinced that this
rebuilding requires different
skills than traditional resilience.
In the wake of trauma, almost everyone
experiences some depression anxiety.
Most go on to move past
those early feelings and
some become psychologically
stronger than they were before.
Psychologists call it
Post Traumatic Growth.
It's what I'm hoping for
when I talk about rebuilding.
You guessed it, I have to pull up
my favorite graph one more time.
In elastic deformation, you bend but
you end up exactly where you were.
In plastic deformation, you bend or break
and you're going to end up different.
What kind of different
depends upon how you rebuild.
Bouncing back and
rebuilding are different skill sets.
Let's develop both.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]